since the dawn of time the stick has
been essential to human survival helping
us explore the world and protect
ourselves but never before in the course
of human history have we seen the sticks
perhaps greatest contribution to
civilization it is enabling the
anatomically impossible extending arms
to take better photos of ourselves and
the sites behind us oh yes
we're talking about this selfie stick
now I know what you're thinking people
are walking around the streets with
their phones on poles I thought the same
thing but stick with me here for a
second there's actually some real
advantages to using one of these you
don't have to ask the stranger to hold
your phone you can capture better wider
angles at yourself and you can record
more stable video I figured if I'm gonna
join this absurd looking trend I should
have the best one that's right
not all selfie sticks are created equal
which is why I've been testing 14 of
them
sure fundamentally a selfie stick is
just a pole with an attachment for your
phone at the end but this one under $20
lets you take a picture with just a
press of a button right on the pole
attach your phone to the top of the 40
inch TV antenna looking pole plug the
cord into the headphone jack and get
shooting
many companies sell the exact same
chinese-made stick the one I tested
called the look DG cost $20 on Amazon
who the Thar sells this one for $15 and
instead of that headphone thing it gives
you this small little Bluetooth remote
it's much more comfortable to hold than
the others but I kept losing this little
thing that's why the $25 pick stick has
bluetooth built right in it works well
though you have to remember to charge
your stick and it can't get wet all of
these sub $30 options have one thing in
common they feel really cheap especially
the part that clasps to your phone if
someone really hated your selfie stick
they could break it right over their
knee if you want something more durable
and waterproof you need to pay more
though I liked the $60 selfie extreme
sometimes called the ultra or expert and
it's comfortable grip the best out of
all of them
there's no shudder gimmick built-in you
have to use a timer or buy a $5
Bluetooth remote but it's sturdy and
works great when I ran into Neil Young
selfie stick everybody should have one
selfie sticks aren't just for family
photos and beauty shots they also really
took off when GoPros did for action
shops I highly recommend GoPros own $70
3 way you can change angles and even
turn it into a tripod I also liked the
$100 power pole this is the Tesla of
selfie sticks and has a built in battery
that recharges phones or GoPros but that
$48.00 quick pod which you can get with
a GoPro mount is lighter now I don't
want to lie to you no matter which one
of these you go with you're still gonna
look pretty ridiculous with your phone
on a stick but if you're ok with that
and I am I'd go with the luke DG on the
cheap and the quick pod selfie extreme
well you could go back and do what our
ancestors did find a stick make your own